Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute machen wir was Leckeres zum Mittagessen.
Ich hab mir überlegt wir machen Rindfleisch Filets aus dem Backofen.
Ich werd sie gleich kurz braten, dann machen wir eine leckere Soße,
dann kann das in der Soße so ein bisschen schmoren, garen.
Ich hab mein Rindfleisch, da nehmt ihr am Besten z.B.
welches aus der Schulter, das mag ich immer ganz gerne.
Das habe ich schon in Scheiben runtergeschnitten. Dann kann das einfach schneller garen
und wir sparen uns auch ein bisschen Zeit.
Ich weiß ja, dass Zeit immer so ein Thema ist beim Mittagessen.
Und das habe ich schon geschnitten in 1 ½cm dicke Schreiben.
Ich gehe jetzt zuallererst rüber zu meiner Pfanne und da gebe ich jetzt Olivenöl rein.
Olivenöl dürft ihr wenn es gut und kaltgepresst ist und nativ extra ist,
nicht heißer als 175-180° C erhitzen.
Daher gehe ich jetzt auf Stufe 7 von 9
und werde dann mein Fleisch von jeder Seite ca. 1min darin anbraten.
Das Fleisch habe ich jetzt rausgenommen und zurück auf den Teller gegeben,
das benötigen wir auch gleich direkt wieder.
Kleiner Tipp von mir: Nehmt euer Fleisch gerne 45-60min zuvor aus dem Kühlschrank
damit es so ein bisschen auf Zimmertemperatur kommen kann und ihr das nicht ganz kalt in die heiße Pfanne gebt.
Sonst lauft ihr Gefahr, dass etwas zäher wird.
So! Jetzt geht's weiter mit unserer leckeren Soße.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt dieselbe Pfanne, hier ist auch noch ein bisschen Olivenöl drin.
Das ist auch gut so, es schmeckt nämlich sehr, sehr gut. Und jetzt kommt Butter dazu.
So, die lasse ich da jetzt drin schmelzen. Auch bei Butter bitte aufpassen!
Nicht zu heiß schmelzen lassen, sonst verbrennt sie, wird dunkel
und dann müsstet ihr alles nochmal neu machen.
Und da gebe ich jetzt auch schon direkt Paprikamark dazu.
Ihr könntet auch Tomatenmark nehmen wenn ihr Paprikamark nicht da habt, das ist auch sehr lecker.
Und dann verrühren wir das.
Das Paprikamark konnte jetzt schön rösten, das hat jetzt nur 1min gedauert.
Und jetzt geben wir Mehl mit dazu und rühren das ständig um.
So, zur Mehlschwitze gebt ihr dann nach und nach warmes Wasser
und rührt das schön um damit keine Klümpchen entstehen.
Jetzt ist bei mir eine sehr, sehr flüssige Creme entstanden sage ich mal,
das wird im Backofen später noch so ein bisschen sämiger.
Und da geben wir jetzt Senf mit dazu, außerdem 2 ganze Knoblauchzehen,
die geben richtig, richtig schön Geschmack ab!
An Gewürzen nehme ich Gemüsebrühe, ein bisschen Chilipulver,
Salz - auch nicht zu viel, je nachdem, wie salzig die Gemüsebrühe schon ist
und frisch gemahlenen Pfeffer.
Und danach kommen wir zum Gemüse.
Im nächsten Schritt eine Zwiebel vierteln,
außerdem Kartoffeln schälen und in kleine Stücke schneiden
und wenn ihr Möhren gern dazunehmen möchtet, dann schneidet die auch in kleine Stücke.
Ihr könntet jetzt eigentlich auch andere Gemüsesorten nehmen aber je nachdem, wie kurz die Garzeit ist,
könnt ihr andere Sachen z.B. auch zum Schluss erst dazugeben.
Wie z.B. Champignons, die ich gerne mit dazugenommen hätte
aber aus Rücksicht zu dir - da Hamza keine Champignons mag, hab ich's jetzt einfach weggelassen.
[Hamza] Danke!
Die könntet ihr dann ganz zum Schluss nach dem Garvorgang mit dazugeben,
die brauchen ja nicht so lange.
So! Die Zwiebel gebe ich jetzt rein, die gibt auch nochmal einen sehr, sehr guten Geschmack ab.
Jetzt kommt zum Fleisch zurück, das Gemüse kommt zurück
und den Backofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 200° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
So, fast hätte ich's vergessen:
Schmoren bitte immer mit Deckel, sonst wird euer Fleisch trocken!
Den Deckel gebe ich da jetzt noch drauf.
Mein Deckel ist bis zu 240° C backofenfest, daher ist das hier überhaupt kein Problem.
Ihr müsst nicht mit Alufolie oder sonst was arbeiten.
Und das schmort jetzt 1h lang und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Ich mach jetzt nebenbei Reis, den habe ich natürlich mit Salz gewürzt und mit Ras el Hanout.
Probiert das unbedingt mal aus, ich verlink euch das natürlich unten in die Infobox.
Das ist in der arabischen Welt mega, mega bekannt.
Und ich finde auch in der deutschen Küche sollte das viel, viel öfter benutzt werden.
Das macht den Reis nämlich nochmal richtig, richtig schön würzig.
So, fertig!
1h ist rum und das Gericht ist fertig.
Ihr müsst euch einfach nur daran halten, dass ihr jetzt Kartoffeln
wirklich in mundgerechte Stücke schneidet damit sie auch wirklich gleichzeitig gar werden.
Und das Fleisch ist jetzt nach der Stunde auch sehr, sehr zart.
Und ich würd mal sagen wir gehen jetzt einfach rüber mit dem leckeren Essen zum Tasty Table
und Hamza probiert dann einfach mal für uns.
Ich an dieser Stelle verabschiede mich schonmal und wünsche euch einen wunderschönen Tag
und natürlich viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] Ich dachte ich mach den Taste Test!
[Kiki] Ich wollt's dir vorschneiden! Ich hab einmal probiert, das schmeckt echt lecker!
[Kiki] Und jetzt musst du einmal probieren!
[Kiki] Wir sind doch Ehemann und Ehefrau, oder?
[Hamza] Ja, gib mir eine neue Gabel!
[Kiki] Dann essen wir von der gleichen Gabel und vom gleichen Teller!
[Hamza] *lacht*
[Hamza] Also ich find's sehr, sehr lecker gewürzt Kiki!
[Hamza] Das Fleisch ist schön zart, super gewürzt!
[Hamza] Also ich kann mich nicht beschweren, ich find's lecker!
[Hamza] Leute - macht's nach, unbedingt!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Kiki hast du echt toll gemacht, ehrlich!
[Kiki] Dankeschön!
[Kiki] Wir lassen uns das jetzt schmecken. Bis dann, Tschüss!
[Hamza] Muss noch den Reis probieren!
[Kiki] Achja!
[Hamza] Mmmh!
[Hamza] Mega!